Let us solve some dots with dots
feature graphs.
The task requires us
to find the coordinates
at each of these points.
Let's do it.
Let's start with this point here.
Let's call it a point.
We begin with the discovery of the x coordinate.
x means how far is left or right from the start point.
And it is 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 left or just
-6 from the origin of the coordinate system.
Minus 6 is right here.
And then y-coordinate, which means how high is the distant point,
right here.
That's 4.
Minus 6 and 4.
Let's do the same for b.
For the x-coordinate
just get down, and that's 7.
And y-coordinate, how high is the point, this is 6.
All right.
Let us now find the coordinates of point c.
the x-coordinate is minus 8.
8 to the left of the system.
minus 8.
And the y coordinate is 2 squares below the start of the system.
So the y coordinate is minus 2.
That is, nothing complicated.
Item d.
Point d, its y coordinate is 4.
No, sorry, her x-coordinate is 4, and then
its y coordinate, how much lower than the start of the system is, or just below
the vertical axis, it is minus 7.
And finally we are on the point is.
Choosing a nice color for the point is.
Right there.
Its x coordinate is 5.
On the abscissa axis x is equal to 5.
And her y coordinate, well, she is neither above nor below
the beginning of the system or the abscissa, so its y coordinate is 0.
We can draw a line and get right to 0.
And so.
We found all these coordinates.
Now, in Task 5
we have to find out whether each dependency is a function.
Here we have a trick that one dependence
is not a function if there are two values ​​for x.
For example.
If I write that f (x) is equal to 5, if x is equal to 1,
or is equal to 6 if x is equal to 1.
That makes no sense.
Why does it make no sense?
Because if I put the number 1 there, I do not know what
result I will get.
Will I get 5?
Or will I get 6?
This is a badly built feature.
This is not a function.
So if we have a similar situation for an argument,
which gives us several different possible outcomes,
this is not a function.
Let's see if there is something like this here.
It is given us first that
if x is 1 then y is 7.
If x is 2, y is 7, well, well.
Yes.
We can have two values ​​for x at one for y.
For example, the same would be to say that f (x) equals 7
if x is equal to 1 or 2.
Everything is fine.
For two different values ​​of x we ​​can have the same result,
but we can not have two different values ​​for x to give us
the same thing, excuse me, that is, we can not have the same value for x for which
to have different results.
Because then we do not know if we have f (1)
how much it will be equal.
f (1), will it be 5 or will it be 6?
We do not know.
Here we know how much f (1) is equal to 7.
Here we know how much f (2) is equal to 7.
So far so good.
So when we have 2, we get 7.
When the argument is 3, we get 8.
If the argument is 4, we get 8.
For example, let's define the function so we get 8
if x is equal to 3 or 4.
Then we have 5.
The function is equal to 9 if x is equal to 5.
For the first paragraph, this is the definition of the function,
fully compliant with definition rules
of the function.
Whatever value you give me 1, 2, 3, 4, or 5, which values ​​are actually
the definition area in the case, I can tell you
what will be the value of the function for each of these points.
They will vary around 7, 8, or 9.
So, for a sub-item we definitely have a function.
Now b subsection.
Let's see if x is 1 and y is 1.
We are told that if x is 1, then y is minus 1.
That makes no sense.
Here's what they tell us here.
Trying to compose a function where they tell us,
that this function will be equal to 1 if x is equal to 1, but
or it will be equal to minus 1 if x is equal to 1.
So when we have f (1), we do not know
how much the function will be equal.
Will it be equal to 1 or minus 1?
We do not know what to take, here or here.
Therefore, this is not a function.
Subpoint b is not a function.
This dependency is not a function.
All right.
Let's cut some more.
Task 6.
Explain by an equation any function graph.
We have this letter-like thing.
We can record it in several ways.
Let's call it f (x).
We can call it g (x) or h (x), but if we have not used it
before we usually use f (x).
This is x.
Let's see we seem to have a straight line when x is
greater than 0, and another straight line when x
is less than 0.
We have one case when x is
greater than 0.
And a separate case when x is less than 0.
And I'll try to connect the two cases for a second.
What do you like this line here like?
When x is 0, y is 0.
When x is 2, y is 1.
When x is 4, y is 2.
It seems that whatever number is x, y always
is 1/2 times less than x.
When x is 6, y is 3.
So it is equal to 1 / 2x when x is greater than 0.
And when x is less than 0 when x is
minus 2, ye 1.
When x is minus 4, y is 2.
It seems that this is exactly 1/2.
Minus 1/2 by minus 4 is 2.
We have 1/2 x when x is less than 0.
It seems like a totally correct answer.
But if we want to make it a little easier,
to clarify it a bit, we can record the function
f (x) is equal to something instead of recording separately
for greater or less than 0, let's take it straight
the absolute value for x and multiply it by 1/2.
Task 10.